Tom craz nikki is co-host of Ronnie and
T craz morning show on our great
affiliate in Tampa W da e house Burrell
with my Buccaneers Tom hold on a second
and I'm coming back down from the clouds
yes it's great by the way 6 7 to 20 ok
not messing with you not messing with
you all right if I told you two weeks
ago Brady was coming to Tampa what would
you have said then I thought there was a
chance and using you heard what Bruce
Arians said at the combine weeks ago and
the Bucs have been at this for weeks it
said listen I pick up the phone I would
call Tom Brady and after how the season
ended on a pick six they finished seven
and nine I left the bad taste in his
mouth and when he found out that Brady
was going to be available the Buccaneers
were really aggressive in pursuing him
this Bruce Arians couldn't help Jameis
Winston but you know he's he's gonna
bring in Tom breed like what what
happens now with that relationship and
this offense
how much is changing in what Bruce
wanted Jameis to do and what he's gonna
ask Tom to do look I think it might be
modified to an extent but Bruce is still
going to take his shots down the field
he's got two wonderful receivers to work
with they still want to run the football
and and Dan look the offensive line is
gonna get upgraded and they're gonna put
more pieces around Brady but I think
there's going to be a give and take
between Brady and airings you look Bruce
is not a fool he's been around the block
he's coached some great quarterbacks you
know how smart and how innovative Tom
Brady is so I think there'll be a
give-and-take within that relationship
yeah and I look at Brady and I
understand why he'd be attracted to this
the offensive line makes me nervous
I like the skilled position I thought
that defense was a top five defense at
the end of the year but you're they're
doing pre and post for the the radio
show
am i overstating what I saw I thought
they were gonna be a playoff team this
year if even if Brady doesn't go there
and they bring in Teddy Bridgewater am i
overstating my Buccaneers not at all
because the defense as you mentioned the
top six games they were in the top five
and defense defensive efficiency and
Jack Barron led the league in sacks he's
back they resigned Jason pierre-paul
went eight and a half stack
limited time he's back there were number
one against the run that secondary was
young but they got much better as time
went on call the Davis did a great job
the last couple of games against the
Andre Hopkins and Julio Jones so that
defense will keep them in games as long
as the offense Dan doesn't turn the
football over which we've seen plenty of
mistakes
I think the Bucks can be in the playoff
so they should be in the playoffs quite
frankly do you think Jameis Winston is
his starting quarterback not now after a
hundred 11 turnovers in five years and
look I like Jameis personally Dan he's
got an electric arm he'll sit back there
and he'll make some throws and rip it
down the field and you'd be like damn
there's only two or three quarterbacks
and all the football that can do that
and then he tries to do too much then
and usually these interceptions have
been on the shorter routes and I'm not
sure if it's depth perception of
whatever it is but he has to understand
when the journey is over to throw the
football away live to fight another down
that's something that Tom Brady does
really well by the way
and I think Winston has the talent to
eventually be a reclamation project he
could be the next Ryan Tannehill where
you go yeah let's just discard him and
somebody will eventually he'll get a
chance if he goes to a team and bides
his time and maybe maybe he doesn't try
to be brett favre that was always my my
problem with him is he tried to make
things happen where the smart
quarterbacks go there's a small window
and if you don't see the window before
it's open it's already closed by the
time you get there and I don't think
Jameis ever processed the game that way
I think you're right a one pack the
Florida State because you was always
that risk taker right always going down
the field and you won a national
championship at Florida State and he
might have thought to himself listen I'm
not going to change who I am because
even though I had 18 interceptions in
one year Florida State I'm still going
to take that risk because they got away
with it look just what in the NFL these
defensive backs they break on these
balls a lot quicker and unfortunately he
found that out the hard way
how could this go wrong with Brady in
Tampa Bay well if the Bucs don't upgrade
the offensive line if he gets hit early
and often if you look at the Bruce Arian
system yeah if you're a quarterback
you're going to get hit but I think the
Bucs are relying on the fact that they
will fortify the offensive line and
then you know you watch Tom Brady for
the last 20 years he's underrated when
it comes to shifting in the pocket
moving he's got great pocket awareness
he will get rid of that football one two
three boom the balls out of his hand
how long do you think Brady plays in
Tampa I think two years I think he and
Bruce Aaron's probably go out after two
years that everyone knows the Super Bowl
is in Tampa this year and all the Bucs
fans are excited but if I had to put a
timetable on it I think he's here for
two years do you think Antonio Brown is
part of this decision that he's coming
to town I sure hope not dad you know I'm
right there with you
as talented as he is if I'm the Bucs I
want him nowhere near my facility as
Chris Godwin already given Brady his
jersey number he probably has look Chris
guy he's a great kid by the way Dan he's
a great kid you will literally give him
the shirt off no he wants the jersey the
jersey off his back Tom I'll give that
you two here's number 12 and then Brady
probably karma check to his favorite
charity and they'll be on with it that's
good hey it's great to check in with you
Tom and thanks for the support there
with our show on WDIA we appreciate your
time
my pleasure dad to you and the dinettes
appreciate it it's Tom Christ Nicky he's
co-host of Ronnie and T crimes morning
show on WD IE Tampa sports radio so host
the Bucs pre and post shows on the
station as well